[Funny Music]
Rutland: We saw the 2011 opportunity
When we noticed a great interest in the mobile world
This is what prompted us to establish Hutch.
We have a studio for mobile applications in London,
Many members of the studio are interested in cars.
We do not care about anything more than our interest in cars,
Especially racing games.
Racing games in the past have been very skillful.
We are looking for new ways to integrate players with different skills.
We take all our toys from our own interests,
We also put a lot of perceptions and models
With game teams.
Our task is to make the game available
To the public as soon as possible.
There is great importance to developers of pilot programs
On Google Play.
This is part of the tools we use
With a view to enhancing the Group's decision-making capacity
So we can then convert
Our own interests to useful data.
Scannel: Google Play lets you switch from a beta
To launch at a personal level and then reach a world-class level,
Get instant feedback from users,
This allows us to examine the actual data
And prepare the best possible game for players.
During the self-launch of MMX Hill Climb,
Take advantage of our store listing experiments
In testing the different colors of symbols,
We discovered the best code that helped improve CTR
At 20% in the Play Store.
Rutland: MMX Hill Climb is a traditional and simplified game of contests.
This game has great social features.
Among the things we discovered through the A / B test
That when we raise the level of difficulty at some point,
Increases the retention level of the player.
SCANNEL: Using the A / B test, we were able to test the stability of the vehicle
We were able to follow the level of difficulty
At the beginning of the game
In order to improve the user experience
And get new players.
Examples of optimization
We looked at how difficult a certain level is.
We found that this particular level takes more than 60 attempts,
This greatly exceeds other levels in the game.
So we were able to focus
At this level to reduce the level of difficulty
Specifically on this level.
Game statistics are very important
Since they provide us with the possibility to get out of this place,
When we create content for updates,
We know what attracts players.
Rutland: MMX Hill Climb exceeded
3 million on Google Play. The time to interact with the game arrived
To approximately 48 minutes a day.
This game is user-friendly
Which is really wonderful.
Skanel: We can take advantage of reviews to know the problems
Which may not necessarily be obvious in statistics.
Reviews can be obtained from ideas for updating content,
They are also useful in motion
Clarify certain features in the game that have not been well explained.
Rutland: Statistics are very important to us.
It helped us improve our users' experience for the first time
In previous games, our level of standing value has also been raised to double.
We are able to attract more than 10 million new players
Via Google Play.
We have increased profits
Over the past four years has tripled.
We also notice a continuous increase in the level of interaction.
We are interested in the long term
To be the best destination developers can rely on
In the best gaming industry.
We are trying to create a dream studio.
[Funny Music]